voy a dibujar una molécula de benceno y
después vamos a pensar en todas las
cosas interesantes que pasan con esta
molécula a ver la molécula de benceno
son 6 carbonos 1
en forma de hexágono ahora las moléculas
de benceno son más interesantes que un
simple ciclohexano porque tiene tres
enlaces dobles un enlace doble por acá
otro enlace doble por acá y un último
enlace doble por acá y sabes que en este
ejemplo también vamos a poner los
hidrógenos para que no se nos olviden a
ver este carbono cuantos hidrógenos
tiene pues aquí tiene 12 3 electrones de
valencia usándose en estos enlaces
entonces le queda un electrón de
valencia para hacer un enlace con un
hidrógeno bueno entonces este otro
carbono implícitamente con cuántos
hidrógenos estamos diciendo que está
enlazado pues a ver tiene 1 2 3 enlaces
escritos por aquí así es que le queda
otro enlace con un hidrógeno y lo mismo
para todos estos aquí le falta un
hidrógeno otro hidrógeno
3 electrones de valencia así es que por
aquí está otro hidrógeno y otro
hidrógeno y esta molécula de aquí se
llama benceno
d
ok es una molécula muy famosa y vas a
aprender un montón de ella en el futuro
sin embargo en este vídeo en particular
estamos muy interesados en una propiedad
en particular del benceno y esa
propiedad que es muy interesante por
cierto se llama resonancia
eso
bueno esto de la resonancia no es una
propiedad única del benceno hay un
montón de moléculas orgánicas que
también tienen esta propiedad de
resonancia sin embargo la resonancia del
benceno es la más divertida entonces
pensemos en qué podría pasar con esta
molécula imaginémonos que tenemos aquí
este electrón de este carbono en este
enlace doble y que de repente a este
electrón se le ocurre irse con este
carbono bueno suponiendo que eso está
pasando este electrón de aquí de este
carbono no se va a mover de este carbono
solo va a funcionar de alguna forma como
un pivote y estos dos electrones van a
seguir asociándose formando un enlace
doble pero ahora el enlace doble va a
ser entre este carbono y este otro
carbono sin embargo una vez que este
electrón ya salto a este carbono este
carbono va a tener 1 2 3 4 5 electrones
y realmente no necesita tantos
electrones
tal vez este electrón va a decidir
saltar a este otro carbono y lo mismo
este electrón de aquí va a seguir
formando un enlace doble con este otro
electrón pero ahora entre este carbono y
este carbono y otra vez este carbono va
a tener 1 2 3 4 5 electrones así es que
va a dejar que este electrón de aquí se
vaya mucho más fácilmente con este
carbono de aquí y este enlace doble va a
terminar siendo un enlace doble entre
estos dos carbonos ok vamos a dibujar
por acá cómo se vería eso aunque sabes
que esta es una flecha en dos
direcciones porque la verdad es que el
benceno puede ir en cualquiera de las
dos direcciones entonces tenemos
nuestros 6 carbonos por aquí formando un
anillo
muy parecido a un ciclo hexano pero
sabemos que tienen por ahí tres enlaces
dobles y déjame corrijo esta parte para
que se vea mejor bueno a ver vamos a
empezar a ponerle colores a estos
electrones para distinguirlos bien por
aquí tenemos a este electrón que ahora
va a ser el electrón verde y resulta que
este electrón salta a este otro carbono
entonces ahora el electrón verde está en
este carbono sin embargo este electrón
de aquí se queda por acá y ahora el
enlace doble que antes estaba por aquí
ahora está por acá o sea que está por
acá ok y lo mismo pasa con este este
electrón naranja salta este carbono
moviendo este enlace para acá ok el
electrón naranja salta de este carbono a
este otro carbono por aquí haciendo que
el enlace doble que antes estaba por
aquí
ahora se mueva por acá y exactamente lo
mismo pasa con este electrón de aquí
antes el electrón morado estaba en este
carbono pero saltó a este otro carbono
de aquí moviendo el enlace doble que
había aquí a este lugar ahora el
verdadero estado del benceno no es
ninguno de estos dos estados y lo que
nos queda aquí es una molécula super
parecida a la que teníamos originalmente
ok lo único que pasó es que movimos
algunos enlaces dobles pero la
estructura que obtuvimos es igualita a
la anterior sólo necesitaríamos rotarla
un poquito y ya tendríamos otra vez esta
molécula claro que estos electrones todo
el tiempo pueden estar soltando y en
cualquier segundo pueden regresar se y
estar otra vez como esta molécula sin
necesidad de rotación sin embargo la
realidad del benceno es que nunca se
encuentra en ninguno de estos dos
estados
está en un punto intermedio hoy vamos a
dibujar el verdadero estado del benceno
ok aquí sólo hemos dibujado los enlaces
simples implícitamente están indicados
ahí todos estos 6 carbonos y los 6
hidrógenos enlazados con los carbonos
que no dibujamos por aquí pero si no los
dibujamos están ahí indicados
implícitamente aunque ahí tenemos 123
electrones de valencia de este carbono y
eso implica que por aquí hay un
hidrógeno hidrógeno
hidrógeno
y
listo ahora el verdadero estado del
benceno entre cada carbono no hay ni un
enlace simple ni un enlace doble ok
porque todos estos electrones están
saltando todo el tiempo de carbono en
carbono moviendo los enlaces dobles de
un lugar a otro entonces en realidad lo
que tenemos es como que medio enlace
doble ok tenemos por aquí medio en láser
doble entre estos dos carbonos porque la
mitad del tiempo hay aquí dos electrones
formando un enlace doble pero la otra
mitad del tiempo hay únicamente un
enlace simple y lo mismo por aquí la
mitad del tiempo hay dos electrones que
están tratando de formar un enlace pi
que es lo que forma el enlace doble al
igual que por acá
y por acá y la otra mitad del tiempo
aquí hay enlaces simples y en estos tres
lados hay electrones que están tratando
de formar enlaces dobles ahora estos
electrones no se quedan entre estos dos
carbonos ok no está en este estado y
luego salta a este estado y luego
regresa a este estado no para nada este
electrón verde tal vez salta de este
carbono a este otro carbono y luego tal
vez salta a este otro carbono pero antes
tal vez este electrón de aquí salto a
este otro carbono y así los electrones
van girando y girando ok el verdadero
estado estable del benceno es este de
aquí
esta es la estructura que tiene el nivel
de energía más bajo que es en el que los
electrones no se quedan estáticos en un
solo carbono sino que siguen moviéndose
de un carbono a otro interminablemente y
ese es el estado en el que se encuentra
el benceno todo el tiempo ese es el
estado con nivel de energía más bajo
y estos otros dos diagramas de louis son
muy importantes y los vemos todo el
tiempo en la química orgánica porque son
las estructuras de contribución y es más
o menos como se vería la molécula si no
tuviera resonancia y generalmente cuando
uno está haciendo una reacción es
muchísimo más fácil y te sirve mucho más
poner una de estas estructuras a poner
esta estructura que refleja la realidad
del benceno ok a la hora de analizar una
reacción es mucho más fácil pensar en
que estos electrones están aquí a decir
no pues no sabemos en qué lugar está en
cada instante podría estar acercándose a
este carbono o alejándose de este
carbono pero bueno estas estructuras se
llaman estructura de contribución o
estructura en resonancia y el benceno no
es la única molécula orgánica que tiene
resonancia hay muchísimas más moléculas
orgánicas que tienen resonancia y justo
ahorita vamos a ver otro ejemplo muy
famoso
vamos a ver el ejemplo de lyon carbonato
y en el ión carbonato lo que tenemos es
un carbono que tiene un enlace doble con
un oxígeno y un enlace simple con dos
oxígenos ahora es un poquito más
complicado que esto porque resulta que
estos dos oxígenos tienen una carga
negativa si colocamos sus electrones
tienen a ver aquí tienen cada uno un
electrón pero luego este oxígeno tiene
sus 6 electrones de valencia 6
electrones de valencia más el electrón
de valencia con el cual está formando un
enlace con el carbono
así es que tiene una carga negativa y lo
mismo con este otro oxígeno tiene el
electrón con el que está formando el
enlace con el carbono
sus 6 electrones de valencia
así es que tiene una carga negativa por
otro lado este oxígeno es un oxígeno
neutro que no tiene ninguna carga extra
ok tenéis sus 6 electrones de valencia y
ningún electrón más ahora lo que pasa de
interesante con este jon carbonato es
que de repente a uno de estos oxígenos
se le ocurre que les sobra este electrón
y que entonces se lo va a pasar al
carbono y simultáneamente como este
carbono está recibiendo un electrón de
este oxígeno que por cierto entonces
deja de tener una carga negativa en el
mismo instante en que está recibiendo un
electrón de este oxígeno este carbono
como no necesita 5 electrones entonces
toma uno de los electrones del enlace
doble con este oxígeno y se lo regresa y
entonces este oxígeno tiene una carga
negativa aunque bueno creo que no es
buena idea pintar esto todavía
organizar a ver veamos cómo se vería
este ion carbonato después de que este
oxígeno le pasó un electrón y este
carbono le pasó un electrón si esto
llegara a suceder entonces pues
tendríamos aquí a nuestro carbono el
oxígeno estaría por aquí pero ahora ya
no tendría un doble enlace tendría un
enlace simple ok tendríamos aquí al
oxígeno con sus seis electrones de
valencia y este electrón este electrón
antes estaba formando un enlace con este
carbono pero el electrón que antes
estaba en el carbono formando el doble
enlace ahora se encuentra en el mismo
oxígeno por aquí y entonces este oxígeno
tiene siete electrones o sea tiene un
electrón de más y por lo tanto tiene una
carga negativa ahora este oxígeno de
aquí que este oxígeno de aquí tenía un
enlace simple tenía sus seis selecciones
de valencia
6 electrones de valencia vamos a dibujar
este electrón un poco más acá para que
no se vea mal y antes tenía 7 electrones
de valencia pero le dio uno de sus
electrones de valencia al carbono o sea
que ahora es el electrón de valencia
está por aquí y está formando un enlace
doble con este oxígeno antes tenía una
carga negativa pero le dio un electrón
al carbono y entonces ya no tiene carga
negativa ya es un oxígeno sin carga y
este oxígeno por aquí pues realmente no
pasa nada con este oxígeno así es que lo
podemos copiar y pegar lo pegamos por
aquí y lo que obtenemos otra vez es un
millón carbonato ok realmente es
igualito a este ión carbonato solo que
un poquito rotado ahora siendo unión
carbonato otra vez cualquiera de estos
electrones puede decidir que se quiere
ir hacia el carbono y no necesariamente
tiene que ser de este oxígeno también
puede ser de este otro oxígeno
pero en el instante en que este electrón
se va hacia el carbono como el carbono
tiene 4 electrones y con ese nuevo
tendría 5 entonces toma uno de los
electrones del enlace doble puede ser
este o puede ser este y se lo regresa al
oxígeno y entonces lo que tenemos es un
carbono a este oxígeno no le pasó nada
copiamos y pegamos por aquí este oxígeno
ahora tiene un enlace simple con el
carbono o sea que tenemos el enlace
simple con el oxígeno que ahora tiene 7
electrones de valencia 1 con este enlace
los otros cinco que ya tenía 1 2 3 4 5
más el electrón morado que le acaba de
regresar el carbono este electrón morado
y entonces tiene una carga negativa y de
este lado se forma un enlace doble entre
el oxígeno y el carbono con estos 2
electrones de aquí
entonces tenemos aquí el oxígeno que
tenía 7 electrones pero solo se va a
quedar con 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 y le regaló un
electrón al carbono y bueno el carbono
tenía estos otros electrones si es que
aquí tiene otro electrón el carbono aquí
está el enlace simple original y aquí
está el enlace doble que se acaba de
formar con este oxígeno y este oxígeno
ya no tiene una carga negativa ok
este es el mecanismo de resonancia del
ion carbonato
jon carbonato
nato y las reacciones se pueden dar en
cualquier dirección obviamente de hecho
de cualquiera de estos tres estados se
puede saltar directamente al cualquiera
de los otros y recuerda que estas son
solo estructuras en resonancia ok
estructuras de contribución en realidad
la realidad de lyon carbonato es que los
electrones están todo el tiempo saltando
entre todos los oxígenos y el carbono a
ver vamos a dibujarlo por aquí tenemos a
un carbono con tres oxígenos tres
oxígenos y siempre hay un enlace simple
entre ellos y también hay otros tres
electrones flotando entre estos átomos
ok pero el carbono sólo puede formar un
enlace w así es que este enlace doble
está moviéndose entre estos tres
oxígenos entonces lo vamos a dibujar así
esta no es ninguna anotación oficial
pero aquí nos referimos a que hay un
tercio de enlace de doble enlace
w así es que en cualquier instante el
enlace doble puede ser entre este
carbono y este oxígeno o con este otro
oxígeno o con este otro oxígeno y los
otros dos electrones van a estar en
cualquiera de los otros dos oxígenos que
no tengan el enlace doble en ese
instante haciendo que tengan una carga
negativa entonces cada oxígeno va a
tener una carga negativa dos terceras
partes del tiempo así es que podríamos
decir que tiene una carga negativa de
menos dos tercios menos dos tercios
y menos dos tercios
en general siempre escribimos alguna de
estas tres estructuras porque es mucho
más fácil lidiar con números enteros y
enlaces dobles enteros pero el estado
real del guión carbonato es este de aquí
donde los electrones realmente están
flotando de un oxígeno al carbono y al
otro oxígeno todo el tiempo aunque están
flotando y saltando en estos enlaces
dobles y alrededor de los oxígenos y de
hecho eso mismo hace que esta molécula
en este estado sea muchísimo más estable
que cualquiera de estas otras tres
estructuras ok
esta estructura es la que tiene el nivel
más bajo de energía la más difícil de
perturbar y lo mismo pasa con el benceno
esta estructura de aquí donde los
electrones van saltando de carbono en
carbono es la estructura más estable la
estructura con el nivel de energía más
bajo